This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。真人保证。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.|||经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 TWO 百分之几，可在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是个重大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.|||我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to.|||在 IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back At It。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关注黑人群体的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行都真的不够安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你需要这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hi, hello, welcome all. Here's the question we're asking ourselves this week. Let's jump right into it. Is social media rotting your brain?
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hi, hello, welcome all. Here's the question we're asking ourselves this week. Let's jump right into it. Is social media rotting your brain?|||在 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。你好，欢迎回到《二三十岁心理学》，这是一个探讨我们在二十几岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变及其对我们心理意味着什么的播客。嗨，大家好，欢迎各位。这是我们本周要自问的问题。让我们直接切入主题。社交媒体在腐蚀你的大脑吗？
And, well, the answer is yes. There you go. End of episode. No, just kidding. This week, we are going to discuss the consequences of social media in our 20s and the absolute chokehold. It has over so many of our lives. I think social media has just recently in the last, you know, decade or two become part of people's daily activities. Many of us spend hours each day on Instagram, Twitter, Facebook, TikTok and other popular social media sites.
And, well, the answer is yes. There you go. End of episode. No, just kidding. This week, we are going to discuss the consequences of social media in our 20s and the absolute chokehold. It has over so many of our lives. I think social media has just recently in the last, you know, decade or two become part of people's daily activities. Many of us spend hours each day on Instagram, Twitter, Facebook, TikTok and other popular social media sites.|||答案是肯定的。好了。本期节目结束。不，开玩笑的。本周，我们将探讨社交媒体对我们二十几岁时产生的影响，以及它对我们许多人生活的绝对掌控。我认为社交媒体只是在最近的一二十年里，才成为人们日常活动的一部分。我们中的许多人每天花几个小时在 Instagram、Twitter、Facebook、TikTok 和其他热门社交媒体网站上。
Hours, hours of our lives detach from the real world, from what is actually happening, you know, connected but not really. There's so much to discuss when we talk about these platforms. We're going to consider the issues of, you know, social comparison and presentation to addiction. We're going to talk about exogenous depression caused by excessive social media usage, how the design of social media is highly intentional and deliberate to capture much of our attention as possible, based on an understanding of how our brains work, how our brains process social information, how these platforms are attuned to tribal networks and the matter by which dopamine controls every single one of our actions. TikTok. We're going to talk about TikTok. Why are those short videos so hard to pull away from
Hours, hours of our lives detach from the real world, from what is actually happening, you know, connected but not really. There's so much to discuss when we talk about these platforms. We're going to consider the issues of, you know, social comparison and presentation to addiction. We're going to talk about exogenous depression caused by excessive social media usage, how the design of social media is highly intentional and deliberate to capture much of our attention as possible, based on an understanding of how our brains work, how our brains process social information, how these platforms are attuned to tribal networks and the matter by which dopamine controls every single one of our actions. TikTok. We're going to talk about TikTok. Why are those short videos so hard to pull away from|||数小时、数小时的生活与现实世界脱节，与实际发生的事情脱节，你知道，表面上连接着但并非真正连接。当我们谈论这些平台时，有太多东西需要讨论。我们要探讨的问题包括，社会比较、自我呈现到成瘾。我们将讨论过度使用社交媒体引起的外源性抑郁，社交媒体的设计如何高度有意识且蓄意地尽可能多地吸引我们的注意力，这基于对我们大脑如何工作、大脑如何处理社交信息的理解，这些平台如何适应部落网络，以及多巴胺控制我们每一个动作的方式。抖音。我们要谈谈抖音。为什么那些短视频那么让人难以抽离？
and why it's probably not your fault that you find yourself in the TikTok deep dive or black hole of content? So much that we're talking about today. So let's just jump right in and answer some of those questions. Humans have been evolving for thousands of years and many, if not all, of our current anatomical features and processes like our limbic system and our dopamine centers, they have adapted from the survival priorities of pre-human and, I guess, human ancestors. And there are a couple of ways that this kind of evolutionary idea is so important when we consider how dominating social media is in our lives these days. In particular, our brains are hardwired towards tribal networks, as this was kind of the best method for organizing members of a group to ensure survival in the past.
and why it's probably not your fault that you find yourself in the TikTok deep dive or black hole of content? So much that we're talking about today. So let's just jump right in and answer some of those questions. Humans have been evolving for thousands of years and many, if not all, of our current anatomical features and processes like our limbic system and our dopamine centers, they have adapted from the survival priorities of pre-human and, I guess, human ancestors. And there are a couple of ways that this kind of evolutionary idea is so important when we consider how dominating social media is in our lives these days. In particular, our brains are hardwired towards tribal networks, as this was kind of the best method for organizing members of a group to ensure survival in the past.|||以及为什么你会发现自己陷入抖音的深度浏览或内容黑洞，这可能并不是你的错？今天我们要谈的内容非常多。所以我们直接切入主题来回答其中一些问题。人类已经进化了数千年，我们的许多（如果不是全部的话）当前解剖学特征和过程，比如我们的边缘系统和多巴胺中心，都是从前人类以及我猜是人类祖先的生存优先级适应而来的。当我们考虑社交媒体如今在我们的生活中占据多大统治地位时，这种进化观点在几个方面都非常重要。特别是，我们的大脑天生倾向于部落网络，因为这过去是组织群体成员以确保生存的最佳方法。
Humans are adapted to be highly social. And despite platforms like Instagram, like Facebook, being created to help humans connect, social media deliberately exploit psychological features of our social brains and dopinergic, doponogenes, to gerigeric systems to mean that we keep going back to receive the reward of feeling like we are part of a broader group and connected to others, even if it's perhaps not true or even if it's just through a screen. As a result of that, I guess, our social media uses has just rapidly increased in the past five years, I'd say, five to ten years. And some researchers have even found reasons to believe that our brains have experienced the kind of rapid evolution that we never see. These been these massive changes to our dopamine systems, our synapses, the size of certain lobes
Humans are adapted to be highly social. And despite platforms like Instagram, like Facebook, being created to help humans connect, social media deliberately exploit psychological features of our social brains and dopinergic, doponogenes, to gerigeric systems to mean that we keep going back to receive the reward of feeling like we are part of a broader group and connected to others, even if it's perhaps not true or even if it's just through a screen. As a result of that, I guess, our social media uses has just rapidly increased in the past five years, I'd say, five to ten years. And some researchers have even found reasons to believe that our brains have experienced the kind of rapid evolution that we never see. These been these massive changes to our dopamine systems, our synapses, the size of certain lobes|||人类适应了高度社交的生活。尽管 Instagram、Facebook 等平台的创建是为了帮助人类建立连接，但社交媒体故意利用了我们的社交大脑以及多巴胺能、多巴胺基因、多巴胺系统等心理特征，这意味着我们不断回去，以获得一种感觉自己是一个更广泛群体的一部分并与他人建立连接的奖励，即使这可能并非事实，或者即使它只是通过屏幕。因此，我想，在过去的五年里，我的意思是五到十年里，我们的社交媒体使用量急剧增加。一些研究人员甚至找到了理由相信，我们的大脑经历了我们从未见过的快速进化。我们的多巴胺系统、突触、某些脑叶的大小都发生了巨大的变化
in children and in young adults that have been noticed since the introduction of social media, changes that would normally take generations, entire generations, to show up in the past. social media it has evolved beyond a platform that connects users. That's not the main purpose anymore. It's now a significant distraction from daily life and many of us prioritize scrolling our feeds or do it counterintuitively without even wanting to. And the negative impacts that have emerged from that are just endless. I'm sure you've experienced that yourself, the use of social media as a distraction,
in children and in young adults that have been noticed since the introduction of social media, changes that would normally take generations, entire generations, to show up in the past. social media it has evolved beyond a platform that connects users. That's not the main purpose anymore. It's now a significant distraction from daily life and many of us prioritize scrolling our feeds or do it counterintuitively without even wanting to. And the negative impacts that have emerged from that are just endless. I'm sure you've experienced that yourself, the use of social media as a distraction,|||自社交媒体引入以来，在儿童和年轻人身上人们注意到了这些变化，这些变化在过去通常需要几代人、整整几代人的时间才会显现出来。社交媒体已经演变成一个超越连接用户平台的工具。这不再是主要目的。它现在成了日常生活中一个严重的干扰源，我们中的许多人把刷动态放在首位，或者在甚至不情愿的情况下反直觉地去做这件事。由此产生的负面影响简直无穷无尽。我相信你一定自己体验过，将社交媒体用作一种分散注意力的工具，
how it removes value from the moment, seeing the world through what we can post to receive attention as a way of connection rather than seeing the world through actually kind of enjoying the moment. So to begin, we are going to examine how social media platforms, you know, like TikTok, like Instagram, have been designed in a very particular and deliberate manner to consume a user.
how it removes value from the moment, seeing the world through what we can post to receive attention as a way of connection rather than seeing the world through actually kind of enjoying the moment. So to begin, we are going to examine how social media platforms, you know, like TikTok, like Instagram, have been designed in a very particular and deliberate manner to consume a user.|||它是如何剥夺当下的价值的，通过我们能发布什么来获得关注并将其作为一种连接方式来看待世界，而不是通过真正享受当下看世界。因此，首先，我们将探讨社交媒体平台（比如 TikTok、Instagram）是如何以一种非常特殊且刻意的方式被设计出来的，以消耗用户。
That's you, the user. Okay, so here's the basis of social media addiction, or at least attraction or attention. Evolutionary psychologists, like we talked about, have observed that pre-human ancestral groups who had greater social connections were more likely to survive because they had greater access to food, because they could divide labor, there were security in numbers, and they had more mating partners. Successful social interactions and the neurotransmitters that are released during these interactions, can be one of the most fulfilling stimuli for humans. Because of the survival benefits of maintaining a large social network in the past,
That's you, the user. Okay, so here's the basis of social media addiction, or at least attraction or attention. Evolutionary psychologists, like we talked about, have observed that pre-human ancestral groups who had greater social connections were more likely to survive because they had greater access to food, because they could divide labor, there were security in numbers, and they had more mating partners. Successful social interactions and the neurotransmitters that are released during these interactions, can be one of the most fulfilling stimuli for humans. Because of the survival benefits of maintaining a large social network in the past,|||也就是你，用户。好的，这就是社交媒体成瘾的基础，或者至少是吸引力和注意力的基础。正如我们所讨论的，进化心理学家观察到，具有更多社会联系的前人类祖先群体更有可能生存下来，因为他们能获得更多的食物，因为他们可以分工合作，人多势众更有安全感，并且他们有更多的交配伴侣。成功的社会交往以及在这些交往过程中释放的神经递质，可以是对人类最充实的刺激之一。由于过去维护庞大社交网络的生存优势，
that instinctual drive towards maintaining expansive networks and groups has survived the evolutionary process. It's still here today. Modern day humans, you and me right now, still place great value in an expansive social network because it's hardwired into our genetic material and certain drives that create our lives. And social media naturally exploits that tribal instinct.
that instinctual drive towards maintaining expansive networks and groups has survived the evolutionary process. It's still here today. Modern day humans, you and me right now, still place great value in an expansive social network because it's hardwired into our genetic material and certain drives that create our lives. And social media naturally exploits that tribal instinct.|||这种对维护庞大网络和群体的本能驱动力在进化过程中生存了下来。它今天依然存在。现代人类，此时此刻的你和我，仍然高度重视庞大的社交网络，因为它已经硬编码到我们的遗传物质以及创造我们生活的某些驱动力中了。而社交媒体自然地利用了这种部落本能。
It says it in the name. Social media. I don't think I'm really confirming anything new with that. But it's really interesting to think about how what once emerged as something that was social, something that was meant to cater to our need for connection, has actually created perhaps more disconnection than previously. So let's do a quick history lesson. Fun fact, trivia time.
It says it in the name. Social media. I don't think I'm really confirming anything new with that. But it's really interesting to think about how what once emerged as something that was social, something that was meant to cater to our need for connection, has actually created perhaps more disconnection than previously. So let's do a quick history lesson. Fun fact, trivia time.|||名字里就写着呢。社交媒体。我觉得我并没有真的证实什么新鲜事。但很有趣的是，去思考曾经作为社交事物出现的东西——旨在迎合我们对连接的需求的东西——实际上可能比以前造成了更多的割裂。所以让我们来上一堂简短的历史课。趣事，冷知识时间。
So a lot of people think that the first social media platform was MySpace. That's not correct. It was this thing called Six Degrees. And it was created in 1997. So six degrees, kind of relating to that idea of six degrees of separation. And it essentially connected users with friends, kind of like what MySpace did after that or what Facebook did after MySpace. So the premise of social media was, and it continues to be, engaging audience. and connecting people online whilst accumulating profits through methods like ad revenue.
So a lot of people think that the first social media platform was MySpace. That's not correct. It was this thing called Six Degrees. And it was created in 1997. So six degrees, kind of relating to that idea of six degrees of separation. And it essentially connected users with friends, kind of like what MySpace did after that or what Facebook did after MySpace. So the premise of social media was, and it continues to be, engaging audience. and connecting people online whilst accumulating profits through methods like ad revenue.|||很多人认为第一个社交媒体平台是 MySpace。这是不对的。它是这个叫做“六度”（Six Degrees）的东西。它创建于 1997 年。所以“六度”，有点像“六度分隔”理论的概念。它本质上是将用户与朋友连接起来，有点像 MySpace 后来所做的事情，或者 Facebook 在 MySpace 之后所做的事情。因此，社交媒体的前提过去是，现在仍然是，吸引受众。并在网上连接人们，同时通过广告收入等方式累积利润。
Capitalism and psychology kind of mixing to create the greatest profits, I guess. And if a site captures more of your attention and you spend more time on it, the more ads they can run and the more they can receive from this income stream. So they have an incentive to capture as much of your finite attention and time as possible. So since this platform, six degrees first launch, more platforms have obviously been created for different needs, all kind of the same one, though, but in different ways. And many people have become so engrossed by this virtual world that they suffer from an addiction to these platforms, which hijack not only their social kind of brain,
Capitalism and psychology kind of mixing to create the greatest profits, I guess. And if a site captures more of your attention and you spend more time on it, the more ads they can run and the more they can receive from this income stream. So they have an incentive to capture as much of your finite attention and time as possible. So since this platform, six degrees first launch, more platforms have obviously been created for different needs, all kind of the same one, though, but in different ways. And many people have become so engrossed by this virtual world that they suffer from an addiction to these platforms, which hijack not only their social kind of brain,|||我想，资本主义和心理学某种程度上融合在一起，创造了最大的利润。如果一个网站能吸引你更多的注意力，你在上面花更多的时间，他们就能投放越多的广告，并从这个收入来源中获得越多。因此，他们有动力尽可能多地夺走你有限的注意力和时间。因此，自从这个平台——六度——首次推出以来，显然为了不同的需求，已经创建了更多的平台，虽然它们基本上都大同小异，只是方式不同。许多人已经对这个虚拟世界着迷到患上了对这些平台的成瘾症，这些平台不仅劫持了他们的社交大脑，
but their reward systems as well. And as these digital kind of technologies as well, like our smartphones become more integrated with everyday life, social media is becoming highly proficient at capturing our attention, whilst kind of producing a global shift, a massive shift in how people gather information and connect with each other. No wonder we're seeing these huge changes in our brain formation. Social media, let's not kid ourselves, it has been specifically designed to be addictive. It exploits psychological processes to not only engage users, but to promote addiction. So in 2017, the ex-president of Facebook, Sean Parker,
but their reward systems as well. And as these digital kind of technologies as well, like our smartphones become more integrated with everyday life, social media is becoming highly proficient at capturing our attention, whilst kind of producing a global shift, a massive shift in how people gather information and connect with each other. No wonder we're seeing these huge changes in our brain formation. Social media, let's not kid ourselves, it has been specifically designed to be addictive. It exploits psychological processes to not only engage users, but to promote addiction. So in 2017, the ex-president of Facebook, Sean Parker,|||还有他们的奖励系统。随着这些数字技术（比如我们的智能手机）与日常生活更加融合，社交媒体在吸引我们注意力方面变得非常熟练，同时在人们收集信息和彼此连接的方式上产生了全球性的转变、巨大的转变。难怪我们看到我们的大脑结构发生了如此巨大的变化。社交媒体，我们别自欺欺人了，它被专门设计成令人上瘾的。它利用心理过程不仅是为了吸引用户，更是为了促进成瘾。所以在 2017 年，Facebook 的前总裁肖恩·帕克，
if you've watched the social network, the movie, it's played by Justin Timberlake, ill, but Sean Parker, the ex-Facebook president, he confirmed that the creators of Facebook deliberately tried to exploit a vulnerability in human psychology when designing Facebook with the objective of consuming as much time and attention as possible or making the platform as addictive as possible.
if you've watched the social network, the movie, it's played by Justin Timberlake, ill, but Sean Parker, the ex-Facebook president, he confirmed that the creators of Facebook deliberately tried to exploit a vulnerability in human psychology when designing Facebook with the objective of consuming as much time and attention as possible or making the platform as addictive as possible.|||如果你看过电影《社交网络》，里面由贾斯汀·汀布莱克扮演，呃，不过肖恩·帕克，Facebook 的前总裁，他证实，Facebook 的创造者在设计 Facebook 时，故意试图利用人类心理学的一个漏洞，其目的是尽可能多地消耗时间和注意力，或者使平台尽可能令人上瘾。
So one feature in particular that he kind of cites that they created to achieve this damaging objective was like the like button. Parker, this ex-president man, he stated in kind of like a public announcement or a public outing against Facebook that the like button it trains users to receive a little dopamine hit from this feature as it brings a sense of social validation and encourages users to engage for longer. Same with the like button on Instagram. Social media, it has the ability then to both capture and scatter your attention because with a simple kind of refresh, there's not only constant new information at your fingertips, but constant possibilities for validation. And the true drive is about attachment to social media, are the hyper-social environments that they offer.
So one feature in particular that he kind of cited that they created to achieve this damaging objective was like the like button. Parker, this ex-president man, he stated in kind of like a public announcement or a public outing against Facebook that the like button it trains users to receive a little dopamine hit from this feature as it brings a sense of social validation and encourages users to engage for longer. Same with the like button on Instagram. Social media, it has the ability then to both capture and scatter your attention because with a simple kind of refresh, there's not only constant new information at your fingertips, but constant possibilities for validation. And the true drive is about attachment to social media, are the hyper-social environments that they offer.|||因此，他列举的一个他们为实现这一破坏性目标而创造的特定功能就像是点赞按钮。帕克，这位前总裁先生，在一项类似公开声明或公开反对 Facebook 的活动中表示，点赞按钮训练用户从这个功能中获得一点多巴胺冲击，因为它带来了社会认可感，并鼓励用户进行更长时间的互动。Instagram 上的点赞按钮也是如此。因此，社交媒体具有捕捉和分散你注意力的能力，因为只要轻轻刷新一下，不仅触手可及有源源不断的新信息，还有源源不断的获得认可的可能性。而对社交媒体依恋的真正驱动力，是它们提供的超级社交环境。
Various methods are used and very successful in keeping our attention because of this innate need for social validation. So when a person uses social media and posts a picture or a status or a video or a reel, they receive a like. They receive positive social feedback and a dopamine hit from the brain. So according to the study by Harvard University, a very big name, social networking, it triggers the same region of your brain that ignites when you use addictive substances. So this rewards the behavior and perpetuates the social media habits that we see these days. The instantaneous gratification from an immediate release of dopamine, that is the basis for addiction and why you can't stop scrolling, why you can't look away. So variably rewarding users with stimuli, so likes, notification, comments, that's what keeps you engaged with content.
Various methods are used and very successful in keeping our attention because of this innate need for social validation. So when a person uses social media and posts a picture or a status or a video or a reel, they receive a like. They receive positive social feedback and a dopamine hit from the brain. So according to the study by Harvard University, a very big name, social networking, it triggers the same region of your brain that ignites when you use addictive substances. This rewards the behavior and perpetuates the social media habits that we see these days. The instantaneous gratification from an immediate release of dopamine, that is the basis for addiction and why you can't stop scrolling, why you can't look away. So variably rewarding users with stimuli, so likes, notification, comments, that's what keeps you engaged with content.|||各种方法被使用并且非常成功地保持了我们的注意力，因为这种对社会认可的先天需求。因此，当一个人使用社交媒体并发布一张照片、一条状态、一个视频或一个短片时，他们会收到一个赞。他们从大脑中获得了积极的社交反馈和多巴胺冲击。因此，根据哈佛大学（一个非常大的名字）的一项研究，社交网络会触发你大脑中与使用成瘾物质时被点燃的相同的区域。这奖励了这种行为，并使我们今天看到的社交媒体习惯永久化。多巴胺瞬间释放带来的即时满足感，这就是成瘾的基础，也是为什么你停不下来地刷屏、为什么你无法移开视线的原因。因此，用刺激（点赞、通知、评论）以可变的方式奖励用户，这就是让你保持对内容参与的原因。
And companies understand what causes those dopamine surges. and lulls. So not just, they're not just interested in what piques your dopamine, but also what reduces it. And it creates their product, their platform, with those hijacking techniques in mind that will trigger compulsion loops. Follow with me here. So the like button, the social validation features, it basically causes your brain to produce dopamine and the companies can use that to create these compulsion loops. The more our brain receives dopamine, from social media, the more the behavior of scrolling your feed or visiting the site is positively reinforced and people crave that instant rush of social affirmation from the dopamine release.
And companies understand what causes those dopamine surges. and lulls. So not just, they're not just interested in what piques your dopamine, but also what reduces it. And it creates their product, their platform, with those hijacking techniques in mind that will trigger compulsion loops. Follow with me here. So the like button, the social validation features, it basically causes your brain to produce dopamine and the companies can use that to create these compulsion loops. The more our brain receives dopamine, from social media, the more the behavior of scrolling your feed or visiting the site is positively reinforced and people crave that instant rush of social affirmation from the dopamine release.|||公司了解是什么导致了多巴胺的激增和低谷。因此，他们不仅对是什么激起你的多巴胺感兴趣，还对是什么减少它感兴趣。他们在设计他们的产品、他们的平台时，牢记了那些会触发强迫循环的劫持技术。跟我一起来。所以点赞按钮、社会认可功能，基本上会促使你的大脑产生多巴胺，而公司可以利用这一点来创建这些强迫循环。我们的大脑从社交媒体中接收到的多巴胺越多，滚动浏览动态或访问网站的行为就越得到正强化，人们就越渴望从多巴胺释放中获得即时的社会肯定。
The variable reinforcement we mentioned earlier is really crucial to this equation. So variable reinforcement. Remember that word or that phrase. So in social media marketing, there is this idea called the hook model. The hook model, it goes beyond reinforcing behavior. It creates habits and it spurs users to act on their own. You no longer need marketing to make people use the platform or to visit it. You no longer need to invest in kind of expensive external stimuli or ads or kind of motivators for people to scroll their feeds. So at the heart of the hook model is a pretty powerful cognitive quirk and it was first described by BF Skinner in the 1950s. BF Skinner, a huge name in psychology. He's done so much for ideas of like conditioning and addiction.
The variable reinforcement we mentioned earlier is really crucial to this equation. So variable reinforcement. Remember that word or that phrase. So in social media marketing, there is this idea called the hook model. The hook model, it goes beyond reinforcing behavior. It creates habits and it spurs users to act on their own. You no longer need marketing to make people use the platform or to visit it. You no longer need to invest in kind of expensive external stimuli or ads or kind of motivators for people to scroll their feeds. So at the heart of the hook model is a pretty powerful cognitive quirk and it was first described by BF Skinner in the 1950s. BF Skinner, a huge name in psychology. He's done so much for ideas of like conditioning and addiction.|||我们之前提到的可变强化对这个公式至关重要。所以是可变强化。记住那个词或那个短语。所以在社交媒体营销中，有一个叫做“钩子模型”（hook model）的概念。钩子模型超越了强化行为。它创造了习惯，并促使联户自行采取行动。你不再需要营销来让人使用这个平台或访问它。你不再需要投资于昂贵的外部刺激、广告或某种激励因素来让人们滚动他们的动态。因此，钩子模型的中心是一个非常强大的认知怪癖，它最早由 B·F·斯金纳（BF Skinner）在 20 世纪 50 年代描述。B·F·斯金纳，心理学界的大牛。他在条件反射和成瘾等理念方面做出了巨大贡献。
And it's called the variable schedule of rewards or intermittent reinforcement. So Skinner, he's most known for this kind of, I don't know, like an experiment, like a, yeah, like a tool. He's best known for these boxes that he kept rats in. And he observed that these rats, they responded most to random rewards. So basically these boxes were used by Skinner to understand how we learn, how humans learn by using rats as like kind of prototypes. And either he punished them. He removed a negative stimulus. He provided a positive stimulus or he removed or he removed a positive stimulus.
And it's called the variable schedule of rewards or intermittent reinforcement. So Skinner, he's most known for this kind of, I don't know, like an experiment, like a, yeah, like a tool. He's best known for these boxes that he kept rats in. And he observed that these rats, they responded most to random rewards. So basically these boxes were used by Skinner to understand how we learn, how humans learn by using rats as like kind of prototypes. And either he punished them. He removed a negative stimulus. He provided a positive stimulus or he removed or he removed a positive stimulus.|||它被称为可变奖励计划或间歇性强化。所以斯金纳，他最著名的就是这种，我不知道，就像一个实验，像一个，是的，就像一个工具。他最著名的是这些他用来关老鼠的箱子。他观察到这些老鼠对随机奖励反应最强烈。所以基本上这些箱子被斯金纳用来了解我们如何学习，人类如何通过把老鼠作为某种原型来学习。他要么惩罚它们。他移除了一个消极刺激。他提供了一个积极刺激，或者他移除了或他移除了一个积极刺激。
So that creates the four types of reward and punishment that we know. Positive and negative reward and positive and negative punishment. So the mice or the rats, they would push or press a lever and sometimes they'd get a small treat. Other times they'd get a large treat and other times they get nothing at all. So unlike the rats in other boxes that when they press a lever, they would receive the same treat every time. the mice that were receiving this kind of variable reward seemed to press this lever more compulsively, more excessively. They pressed it even when they weren't hungry and they became obsessed with it. So humans like the mice in Skinner's box, we crave predictability and we struggle to find patterns when none exist.
So that creates the four types of reward and punishment that we know. Positive and negative reward and positive and negative punishment. So the mice or the rats, they would push or press a lever and sometimes they'd get a small treat. Other times they'd get a large treat and other times they get nothing at all. So unlike the rats in other boxes that when they press a lever, they would receive the same treat every time. the mice that were receiving this kind of variable reward seemed to press this lever more compulsively, more excessively. They pressed it even when they weren't hungry and they became obsessed with it. So humans like the mice in Skinner's box, we crave predictability and we struggle to find patterns when none exist.|||这就构成了我们所知道的四种奖惩类型。正向和负向奖励以及正向和负向惩罚。所以老鼠，它们会推或按一个杠杆，有时它们会得到一小块零食。其他时候它们会得到一大块零食，还有的时候它们什么也得不到。所以与在其他箱子里按下杠杆每次都能得到相同零食的老鼠不同。那些接受这种可变奖励的老鼠似乎更强迫性地、更过度地按下这个杠杆。它们甚至在不饿的时候也按，并且对此着迷。因此，人类就像斯金纳箱子里的老鼠一样，我们渴望可预测性，当不存在规律时，我们拼命想找出规律。
So variability is kind of the brain's cognitive nemesis. and our minds, they want to understand the cause and effect of how things come to be. And we really can't understand those ambiguous situations. So instead of leaving it, we kind of become more obsessed with knowing the pattern of the reward. And we become more engaged in receiving the reward because we kind of have expectation now. So let's explain this a bit further as to how these ambiguous situations, kind of and kind of feed into variable rewards and addiction. So variable rewards, they keep the brain occupied because we want to find out that cause
So variability is kind of the brain's cognitive nemesis. and our minds, they want to understand the cause and effect of how things come to be. And we really can't understand those ambiguous situations. So instead of leaving it, we kind of become more obsessed with knowing the pattern of the reward. And we become more engaged in receiving the reward because we kind of have expectation now. So let's explain this a bit further as to how these ambiguous situations, kind of and kind of feed into variable rewards and addiction. So variable rewards, they keep the brain occupied because we want to find out that cause|||所以多变性可以说是大脑认知的克星。而我们的思维，它们想要理解事物是如何产生的因果关系。我们确实无法理解那些模棱两可的情况。所以与其置之不理，我们反而变得更加痴迷于了解奖励的模式。并且我们更多地参与到接受奖励中去，因为我们现在有了某种期待。所以让我们进一步解释一下这些模棱两可的情况是如何助长可变奖励和成瘾的。因此，可变奖励让大脑忙个不停，因为我们想找出那种因果关系
and effect of when we're going to receive something and we become obsessed with it. It removes our defenses and it removes our kind of cognitive controls. And that's how, you know, either the teacher, in this case, Skinner or social media platforms have the opportunity to plant these seeds of new habits and these compulsions. This is how social media gets to us. It doesn't tell us when we might receive something we particularly like. So we'll try and find that pattern ourselves and therefore we become integrated into the very technology that we are addicted to
and effect of when we're going to receive something and we become obsessed with it. It removes our defenses and it removes our kind of cognitive controls. And that's how, you5 know, either the teacher, in this case, Skinner or social media platforms have the opportunity to plant these seeds of new habits and these compulsions. This is how social media gets to us. It doesn't tell us when we might receive something we particularly like. So we'll try and find that pattern ourselves and therefore we become integrated into the very technology that we are addicted to|||以及我们什么时候能得到某东西的效应，我们对此着迷。它消除了我们的防御，消除了我们的某种认知控制。这就是为什么，你知道，无论是老师——在这个例子中是斯金纳——还是社交媒体平台，都有机会种下这些新习惯和强迫行为的种子。这就是社交媒体如何控制我们的。它不告诉我们什么时候可能会得到我们特别喜欢的东西。所以我们会试着自己去寻找那个规律，因此我们融入了我们所沉迷的那项技术中
because we're obsessed with it. We compulsively press the lever to use that kind of mice example. It's the same with platforms like TikTok now. But this platform has added something, extra special into the mix. That has already been used by other platforms, but has been especially fine-tuned on TikTok in particular. So what does TikTok do well that other platforms also do, but haven't quite gotten the perfect formula for? Algorithms. Algorithms. They are such astonishing tools for creating addictive platforms because they create a virtual world that is
because we're obsessed with it. We compulsively press the lever to use that kind of mice example. It's the same with platforms like TikTok now. But this platform has added something, extra special into the mix. That has already been used by other platforms, but has been especially fine-tuned on TikTok in particular. So what does TikTok do well that other platforms also do, but haven't quite gotten the perfect formula for? Algorithms. Algorithms. They are such astonishing tools for creating addictive platforms because they create a virtual world that is|||因为我们对此着迷。我们强迫性地按下杠杆，套用那种老鼠的例子。现在像 TikTok 这样的平台也是如此。但这个平台在其中加入了一些非常特别的东西。这些东西已经被其他平台使用过，但特别在 TikTok 上得到了精细调整。那么 TikTok 做得很好而其他平台也做但还没完全掌握完美公式的是什么呢？算法。算法。它们是打造令人上瘾的平台的惊人工具，因为它们创造了一个虚拟世界，
perfectly curated to the things that you like and the things that the platform now knows you'll want to consume and come back to. So a social media algorithm, it's a compilation of data and rules that will make decisions almost for you about what you see on a platform. The social media site, it creates unique algorithms for every single person, every single user, which means that no two people will have the exact same social media news feeds. You know, besides, issues of privacy. There's also this issue of cognitive exploitation. By monitoring a user's online behavior and harvesting their private data, they manipulate what they can see online. And this is a form of manipulation known as surveillance capitalism. These social media algorithms,
perfectly curated to the things that you like and the things that the platform now knows you'll want to consume and come back to. So a social media algorithm, it's a compilation of data and rules that will make decisions almost for you about what you see on a platform. The social media site, it creates unique algorithms for every single person, every single user, which means that no two people will have the exact same social media news feeds. You know, besides, issues of privacy. There's also this issue of cognitive exploitation. By monitoring a user's online behavior and harvesting their private data, they manipulate what they can see online. And this is a form of manipulation known as surveillance capitalism. These social media algorithms,|||这个世界根据你喜欢的东西以及平台现在知道你想消费并再次回来看的东西进行了完美的策划。因此，社交媒体算法是数据和规则的汇编，它几乎可以为你决定你在平台上看到的内容。社交媒体网站为每个人、每个用户创建独特的算法，这意味着没有两个人的社交媒体动态是完全相同的。你知道，除了隐私问题。还有一个认知剥削的问题。通过监控用户的在线行为并收集他们的私人数据，他们操纵用户在网上看到的内容。这是一种被称为监视资本主义的操纵形式。这些社交媒体算法，
they work without any oversight and they work 24-7 to keep the users addicted to liking and scrolling through endless ads and content, because although that variable reward is present, your overall experience with the app is likely to be more pleasant because you're seeing the things that kind of pertain to you. So the hijacking of our reward system that we've seen with variable reinforcement and with the addition of things like the like button, it's furthered by this neurological process called long-term potentiation or LTP. So long-term pretentiation, it's the process in which neural pathways that are used frequently, they become stronger. It's kind of the opposite of use it or lose it. As the pathways associated with social media use are exploited more frequently, they become stronger creating the compulsion.
they work without any oversight and they work 24-7 to keep the users addicted to liking and scrolling through endless ads and content, because although that variable reward is present, your overall experience with the app is likely to be more pleasant because you're seeing the things that kind of pertain to you. So the hijacking of our reward system that we've seen with variable reinforcement and with the addition of things like the like button, it's furthered by this neurological process called long-term potentiation or LTP. So long-term pretentiation, it's the process in which neural pathways that are used frequently, they become stronger. It's kind of the opposite of use it or lose it. As the pathways associated with social media use are exploited more frequently, they become stronger creating the compulsion.|||它们在没有任何监督的情况下工作，并且全天候 24/7 运作，让用户对点赞和滚动浏览无休止的广告和内容上瘾，因为尽管存在这种可变奖励，你对该应用程序的整体体验可能更愉快，因为你看到的是与你相关的事情。因此，我们在可变强化以及添加点赞等功能时看到的对我们奖励系统的劫持，被一种称为“长期增强”（LTP）的神经过程进一步推进了。所以长期增强，是经常使用的神经通路变得更强的过程。这有点像“不用进废”（use it or lose it）的反面。随着与使用社交媒体相关的通路被更频繁地利用，它们变得更强，从而产生了强迫行为。
The more we open the app, the stronger these links between our synapses become. And if you have an iPhone, you can actually see this on your phone. You can see this compulsion that's kind of operating separate from probably your own intentions. So take a second now, grab your phone, and I want you to go to the section of your settings that tells you your screen time. worried about that. Scroll down and you'll find this section called first used after pickup. How many times after you pick up your phone has the next thing you've done been open an app like Instagram, Facebook or TikTok? Okay, I'll be honest. I'm recording this early in the morning and already I have 40 total pickups of my phone and of those 15 are for Instagram, almost
The more we open the app, the stronger these links between our synapses become. And if you have an iPhone, you can actually see this on your phone. You can see this compulsion that's kind of operating separate from probably your own intentions. So take a second now, grab your phone, and I want you to go to the section of your settings that tells you your screen time. worried about that. Scroll down and you'll find this section called first used after pickup. How many times after you pick up your phone has the next thing you've done been open an app like Instagram, Facebook or TikTok? Okay, I'll be honest. I'm recording this early in the morning and already I have 40 total pickups of my phone and of those 15 are for Instagram, almost|||我们打开应用程序的次数越多，我们突触之间的这些联系就越强。如果你有一部 iPhone，你实际上可以在手机上看到这一点。你可以看到这种强迫行为，它独立于你自己的意图在运作。所以现在花一秒钟，拿起你的手机，我希望你进入设置中显示你屏幕时间的部分。别担心那个。向下滚动，你会发现一个名为“拿起后首次使用”的部分。在你拿起手机后，接下来紧接着打开 Instagram、Facebook 或 TikTok 等应用的情况有多少次？好吧，老实说。我是在清晨录制这个节目的，我已经总共拿起手机 40 次了，其中 15 次是为了 Instagram，几乎
half. I don't even get notifications for Instagram. It has become a compulsion. The site doesn't even need to advertise to me. It doesn't even need to motivate me. I have been overtaken by the hook model whereby they no longer have to persuade me to use the app. I do it naturally without even consciously thinking about it. I don't even think about it anymore. And long-term potentiation is responsible for those behaviors because those kind of cause and effect behaviors I have, okay, I see my phone, I pick it up. My first thought is social media. It's become, like I said, a habit because I've frequently checked it in the past. And I continue to do it because I'm craving that reward, but also because the more I use it, the stronger those synaptic connections that associate my
half. I don't even get notifications for Instagram. It has become a compulsion. The site doesn't need to advertise to me. It doesn't need to motivate me. I have been overtaken by the hook model whereby they no longer have to persuade me to use the app. I do it naturally without even consciously thinking about it. I don't even think about it anymore. And long-term potentiation is responsible for those behaviors because those kind of cause and effect behaviors I have, okay, I see my phone, I pick it up. My first thought is social media. It's become, like I said, a habit because I've frequently checked it in the past. And I continue to do it because I'm craving that reward, but also because the more I use it, the stronger those synaptic connections that associate my|||有一半。我甚至不接收 Instagram 的通知。这已经成了一种强迫症。这个网站不需要向我做广告。它不需要激励我。我已经落入了钩子模型的掌控之中，他们不再需要说服我使用该应用程序。我自然而然地这样做，甚至没有有意识地去想它。我甚至不再去想它了。长期增强效应对这些行为负有责任，因为我有那种因果行为，好吧，我看到我的手机，我把它拿起来。我的第一个想法是社交媒体。它已经变成了，正如我所说，一种习惯，因为我过去经常查看它。我继续这样做是因为我渴望得到那个奖励，但也因为我用得越多，将我的手机与我从社交媒体获得的多巴胺联系起来的那些突触连接就越强。
phone with the dopamine I get from social media, the stronger those connections become. And this, exploitation has obviously raised some pretty serious debate over whether or not social media should be regulated, or at least algorithms should be regulated. You know the other thing that really scares me about social media, particularly Instagram for me, is that if someone asked me to remember, to recount, to recall anything I'd seen on Instagram from the past week, I wouldn't be able to tell you the details of a singular post. So I spend at least probably an hour or two a day on that platform. Those hours are completely empty. I have absolutely no memory of what it was that even captured my attention or anything I saw. I'm completely blind to those hours. And that's really
phone with the dopamine I get from social media, the stronger those connections become. And this, exploitation has obviously raised some pretty serious debate over whether or not social media should be regulated, or at least algorithms should be regulated. You know the other thing that really scares me about social media, particularly Instagram for me, is that if someone asked me to remember, to recount, to recall anything I'd seen on Instagram from the past week, I wouldn't be able to tell you the details of a singular post. So I spend at least probably an hour or two a day on that platform. Those hours are completely empty. I have absolutely no memory of what it was that even captured my attention or anything I saw. I'm completely blind to those hours. And that's really|||手机和从社交媒体获得的多巴胺之间的联系越强，这些连接就越紧密。这种剥削显然引起了一些非常严重的争论，关于社交媒体是否应该受到监管，或者至少算法是否应该受到监管。你知道社交媒体——对我来说尤其是 Instagram——让我感到害怕的另一件事是，如果有人让我记住、复述、回忆过去一周我在 Instagram 上看到的任何东西，我都无法告诉你任何一个帖子的细节。所以我每天至少花一两个小时在那个平台上。那些时间完全是空洞的。我完全不记得是什么吸引了我的注意力或我看到的任何东西。我对那些时间完全视而不见。这真的
terrifying. Before we talk about, you know, even social comparison, I want to explain a bit more about what social media does to our neural networks. We've talked about dopamine. We've talked about long-term potentiation. But of course, there's more to it. So, heaps of studies have been done it's really interesting in terms of social psychology, yes, but also biological psychology and how our brains have adapted around this new important institution of our daily lives, because that's what it is. Social media is an institution. So heavy social media uses they, and that, okay, I'm just going to say heavy social media is an hour or more a day. I'm guessing all of us meet that criteria. So these users, they perform worse on cognitive tests,
terrifying. Before we talk about, you know, even social comparison, I want to explain a bit more about what social media does to our neural networks. We've talked about dopamine. We've talked about long-term potentiation. But of course, there's more to it. So, heaps of studies have been done it's really interesting in terms of social psychology, yes, but also biological psychology and how our brains have adapted around this new important institution of our daily lives, because that's what it is. Social media is an institution. So heavy social media uses they, and that, okay, I'm just going to say heavy social media is an hour or more a day. I'm guessing all of us meet that criteria. So these users, they perform worse on cognitive tests,|||太可怕了。在我们讨论，你知道，甚至是社会比较之前，我想更多地解释一下社交媒体对我们的神经网络做了什么。我们讨论过多巴胺。我们讨论过长期增强。但当然，远不止于此。所以，已经做了大量的研究，从社会心理学来看这非常有趣，是的，从生物心理学来看也是如此，以及我们的大脑如何围绕这个我们日常生活中的新重要机构进行适应，因为事实确实如此。社交媒体是一个机构。因此，重度社交媒体使用者，还有那个，好吧，我只想说重度社交媒体是指一天一个小时或更长时间。我猜我们所有人都符合这个标准。所以这些用户在认知测试中的表现更差，
especially those that require attention and the ability to multitask. So compared to moderate or light social media users, heavy users, we need to exert more effort to maintain focused or to maintain focus, to remain focused or maintain focus in the face of distraction. And researchers have hypothesized that since social media is easily accessible and competes for our attention with the promise of perpetual new content, heavy social media uses, they actually become less able to ignore distraction in general. Not only does this lead to poor cognitive performance, but it actually shrinks the part of the brain
especially those that require attention and the ability to multitask. So compared to moderate or light social media users, heavy users, we need to exert more effort to maintain focused or to maintain focus, to remain focused or maintain focus in the face of distraction. And researchers have hypothesized that since social media is easily accessible and competes for our attention with the promise of perpetual new content, heavy social media uses, they actually become less able to ignore distraction in general. Not only does this lead to poor cognitive performance, but it actually shrinks the part of the brain|||特别是那些需要注意力和多任务处理能力的项目。因此，与中度或轻度社交媒体用户相比，重度用户，我们需要付出更多的努力来保持专注，或者在面对干扰时保持专注。研究人员假设，由于社交媒体易于获取，并且以源源不断的新内容承诺来争夺我们的注意力，重度社交媒体用户实际上变得更不具备普遍忽略干扰的能力。这不仅会导致认知表现不佳，而且实际上会缩小大脑中
associated with maintaining attention. So the ability of the brain to change is called neuroplasticity. Neuoplasticity, and it has a big effect on your attention and cognitive function. Research it also shows that heavy social media, media use is linked with memory deficits, especially in your transactive memory. This kind of memory involves deciding what kind of information is important to store in your brain and what kind of information can kind of be outsourced. So social media's central feature, the sharing and storing of your experiences, may actually be altering which memories you keep and which ones you don't. So in one study, the participants, they were asked to record an experience using their notes or social media,
associated with maintaining attention. So the ability of the brain to change is called neuroplasticity. Neuoplasticity, and it has a big effect on your attention and cognitive function. Research it also shows that heavy social media, media use is linked with memory deficits, especially in your transactive memory. This kind of memory involves deciding what kind of information is important to store in your brain and what kind of information can kind of be outsourced. So social media's central feature, the sharing and storing of your experiences, may actually be altering which memories you keep and which ones you don't. So in one study, the participants, they were asked to record an experience using their notes or social media,|||与保持注意力相关的部分。因此，大脑改变的能力被称为神经可塑性。神经可塑性，它对你的注意力和认知功能有很大的影响。研究还表明，重度社交媒体的使用与记忆缺陷有关，尤其是在你的交互记忆中。这种记忆涉及决定什么样的信息在大脑中储存是重要的，什么样的信息可以被外包。因此，社交媒体的核心功能——分享和储存你的体验，可能实际上正在改变你保留哪些记忆以及丢弃哪些记忆。所以在的一项研究中，参与者被要求使用他们的笔记或社交媒体记录一次体验，
and the other groups were asked to simply experience the event without recording it, without noting anything down. And at the end of the study, those who had recorded or shared the event performed worse and showed more memory deficit than those who had just experienced the event organically without recording it. So externalising an experience, putting it on social media, it worsened the participant's memory because their brains, the brain has kind of received this message that they didn't need to hold on to the information anymore. It was stored elsewhere. So consequently, not only did the
and the other groups were asked to simply experience the event without recording it, without noting anything down. And at the end of the study, those who had recorded or shared the event performed worse and showed more memory deficit than those who had just experienced the event organically without recording it. So externalising an experience, putting it on social media, it worsened the participant's memory because their brains, the brain has kind of received this message that they didn't need to hold on to the information anymore. It was stored elsewhere. So consequently, not only did the|||而其他组则被要求简单地体验该事件而不记录它，不记下任何东西。在研究结束时，那些记录或分享了该事件的人表现更差，并且表现出比那些只是自然体验该事件而没有记录的人更多的记忆缺陷。因此，将体验外部化，将其发布到社交媒体上，会恶化参与者的记忆，因为他们的大脑、大脑收到了这样一条信息，即他们不再需要保留这些信息了。它被存储在别处。因此，不仅
individuals lose some memory of their original experience, but they also experience longer term deficits in the size and functions of their brain if they use social media again and again and again. And these consequences, they're like genuinely terrifying, especially when you consider young kids now who are going to grow up with social media present in their lives from day, from day one. You know, I kind of feel grateful. at least me, you probably, if you're on your 20s, if you're over the age of 20, at least we kind of got a chance to have some years without it back when our parents were just kind of worried about the TV and not this like evil capitalist invention at our fingertips
individuals lose some memory of their original experience, but they also experience longer term deficits in the size and functions of their brain if they use social media again and again and again. And these consequences, they're like genuinely terrifying, especially when you consider young kids now who are going to grow up with social media present in their lives from day, from day one. You know, I kind of feel grateful. at least me, you probably, if you're on your 20s, if you're over the age of 20, at least we kind of got a chance to have some years without it back when our parents were just kind of worried about the TV and not this like evil capitalist invention at our fingertips|||个人失去了对他们最初体验的一些记忆，而且如果他们一遍又一遍地使用社交媒体，他们的大脑大小和功能也会经历更长期的缺陷。这些后果真的是令人毛骨悚然，尤其是当你考虑到现在的幼儿时，他们从小（从第一天起）就在社交媒体充斥的生活中长大。你知道，我内心感到有点庆幸。至少对我来说，你可能也是，如果你二十几岁，如果你年龄超过 20 岁，至少我们有机会在没有它的日子里度过一些年头，那时我们的父母只是有点担心电视，而不是像这个触手可及的邪恶资本主义发明那样
that is individually curated to be addictive just for you. We've talked about addiction now. We've talked about the neural connections and how social media kind of changes them, how it manipulates them. But another result, of trapping users in this endless kind of scrolling loop of content is that it can lead to social comparison. It's perhaps one of the biggest things that people, you know, are scared about or talk about when they talk about social media. I don't know what has been about my life recently, but I have been so weak to this, so weak to social comparison. And it's often things like Instagram that are the catalyst every single time. You know, people's perfectly curated lives with their endless
that is individually curated to be addictive just for you. We've talked about addiction now. We've talked about the neural connections and how social media kind of changes them, how it manipulates them. But another result, of trapping users in this endless kind of scrolling loop of content is that it can lead to social comparison. It's perhaps one of the biggest things that people, you know, are scared about or talk about when they talk about social media. I don't know what has been about my life recently, but I have been so weak to this, so weak to social comparison. And it's often things like Instagram that are the catalyst every single time. You know, people's perfectly curated lives with their endless|||它专门为你量身定制并令人上瘾。我们现在已经讨论了成瘾。我们讨论了神经网络以及社交媒体如何改变它们、如何操纵它们。但将用户困在这个无休止的内容滚动循环中的另一个结果是，它会导致社会 comparison（社会比较）。这也许是人们在谈论社交媒体时最害怕或谈论的事情之一。我不知道我最近的生活是怎么了，但我对这一点毫无抵抗力，对社会比较毫无抵抗力。而每一次的催化剂往往都是 Instagram 之类的东西。你知道，人们精心策划的生活，有着无休止的
cycle of friends and gorgeous outfits and money to spend on restaurants. I'm envious. But then I'll have people turn around to me and say things like, oh, you know, you look so happy now. You're flourishing. You look like you're having so much fun. And the only thing that they have to judge that by is what I post on social media. These people, they haven't seen me for months. And the impression they get is that my life is going really well. Let me just say that has not been the case. Like, I have. I had my heartbroken recently. I had someone really hurt me, like really bad, and I've just been at such a low point in terms of my self-esteem and sense of value. You know, in the past six months, I've lost countless friends as I've moved and evolved and shifted into this new version of
cycle of friends and gorgeous outfits and money to spend on restaurants. I'm envious. But then I'll have people turn around to me and say things like, oh, you know, you look so happy now. You're flourishing. You look like you're having so much fun. And the only thing that they have to judge that by is what I post on social media. These people, they haven't seen me for months. And the impression they get is that my life is going really well. Let me just say that has not been the case. Like, I have. I had my heartbroken recently. I had someone really hurt me, like really bad, and I've just been at such a low point in terms of my self-esteem and sense of value. You know, in the past six months, I've lost countless friends as I've moved and evolved and shifted into this new version of|||朋友聚会、华丽的服装和用来去餐馆吃饭的钱。我很嫉妒。但随后会有人转过身来对我说，哦，你知道，你现在看起来好快乐。你过得很滋润。你看起来玩得很开心。而他们用来判断这一点的唯一依据就是我在社交媒体上发布的内容。这些人，他们已经几个月没见我了。他们得到的印象是我的生活过得很好. 我只想说事实并非如此。比如，我有。我最近心碎了。我被某个人深深地伤害了，伤得很深，在自尊心和价值感方面，我正处于一个如此低谷的时期。你知道，在过去的六个月里，随着我搬迁、成长并转变为这个全新的版本的
myself. I spent like days alone, hours kind of crying over this person who was never going to love me back. And I've spent hours looking at other people's lives through social media, thinking that they have everything going for them whilst they're thinking the same thing about me. And it's kind of a bit of a fucked game. It's a facade. We choose those best moments when we are smiling or watching a sunset, out partying with friends,
myself. I spent like days alone, hours kind of crying over this person who was never going to love me back. And I've spent hours looking at other people's lives through social media, thinking that they have everything going for them whilst they're thinking the same thing about me. And it's kind of a bit of a fucked game. It's a facade. We choose those best moments when we are smiling or watching a sunset, out partying with friends,|||我自己。我独自度过了好几天，花了几个小时为这个永远不会回爱我的人哭泣。我花了几个小时通过社交媒体看别人的生活，认为他们拥有一切顺利的事情，而他们也在对我产生同样的看法。这有点像一场扯淡的游戏。这只是一个外表。我们选择那些最好的时刻，当我们微笑着或看着日落，和朋友出去聚会，
and the other 99% that's unaccounted for. But we judge people on the 1%. And those comments that I got from a few people, actually, just really made me realize that idea so deeply for the first time, even though it's common knowledge. You know, we do only share the best moments of our lives, but that becomes the source of so much social comparison. And you don't really realize it until you feel it personally, until you see it.
and the other 99% that's unaccounted for. But we judge people on the 1%. And those comments that I got from a few people, actually, just really made me realize that idea so deeply for the first time, even though it's common knowledge. You know, we do only share the best moments of our lives, but that becomes the source of so much social comparison. And you don't really realize it until you feel it personally, until you see it.|||而另外 99% 却不为人知。但我们根据这 1% 来评判别人。而我从几个人那里得到的那些评论，实际上，真的让我第一次如此深刻地认识到这个想法，尽管这是常识。你知道，我们确实只分享我们生活中最好的时刻，但这成了大量社会比较的根源。在你亲自感受到它、看到它之前，你并不会真正意识到这一点。
So when presented with the curated feeds of other people, we are vulnerable to frequent and pretty extreme upward social comparison, which can lead to a number of other negative side effects, some of which I've talked about, you know, the erosion of self-esteem, a depressed mood, and decreased life satisfaction. overall. So social comparison, it's a form of sociological self-esteem where we derive our sense of self through comparing ourselves with others. Many studies have argued that people have a tendency to make downward social comparisons with those who are worse off or less skilled than them, and this raises
So when presented with the curated feeds of other people, we are vulnerable to frequent and pretty extreme upward social comparison, which can lead to a number of other negative side effects, some of which I've talked about, you know, the erosion of self-esteem, a depressed mood, and decreased life satisfaction. overall. So social comparison, it's a form of sociological self-esteem where we derive our sense of self through comparing ourselves with others. Many studies have argued that people have a tendency to make downward social comparisons with those who are worse off or less skilled than them, and this raises|||因此，当面对其他人精心策划的动态时，我们很容易受到频繁且相当极端的向上社会比较的影响，这会导致许多其他负面副作用，其中一些我已经谈过了，你知道的，自尊心的侵蚀、抑郁的情绪以及生活满意度的整体下降。所以社会比较，这是一种社会学意义上的自尊，我们通过与他人比较来获得自我感。许多研究认为，人们有一种倾向，即与那些境况更糟或技能不如自己的人进行向下的社会比较，这会提高
your self-esteem, obviously at the expense of that other person, and then conversely have upward social comparisons and this reduces social, this reduces self-esteem and it's more likely with social media. That's when you kind of, you see someone who is more skilled than you, doing better than you, happier than you. Can you kind of see where we're going with this? So there's this guy he's named Alfred Adler and he said to be human is to have inferiority feelings. And in the age of social media, this is potentially definitely heightened and amplified. social comparison in the real world usually involves the self, you and a few other people. Whilst in the digital universe of social media, you're kind of presented with limitless potential
your self-esteem, obviously at the expense of that other person, and then conversely have upward social comparisons and this reduces social, this reduces self-esteem and it's more likely with social media. That's when you kind of, you see someone who is more skilled than you, doing better than you, happier than you. Can you kind of see where we're going with this? So there's this guy he's named Alfred Adler and he said to be human is to have inferiority feelings. And in the age of social media, this is potentially definitely heightened and amplified. social comparison in the real world usually involves the self, you and a few other people. Whilst in the digital universe of social media, you're kind of presented with limitless potential|||你的自尊心，显然这是以牺牲另一个人为代价的，相反会有向上的社会比较，这会减少社会的、这会减少自尊心，并且在社交媒体上更有可能发生这种情况。那就是当你有时候，你看到某人比你更有技能，比你过得更好，比你更快乐。你能看出我们要表达什么了吗？所以有个叫阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒（Alfred Adler）的人，他说作为人就会有自卑感。而在社交媒体时代，这潜在地绝对被加剧和放大了。现实世界中的社会比较通常涉及自我、你和其他几个人。而在社交媒体的数字世界中，你面对的是无限的潜力
to compare yourself to other people. Limitless, there's thousands. And research predating social media, it estimated that the average person, you know, back in the 90s, back in the 1900s, had perhaps 10 to 20 close relationships and maybe 150 people in their wider social circle. So that includes, you know, like friends of your parents, colleagues, people you kind of know. Whereas now, that number of wider social acquaintances, because of social media, it's up to around 400. So whilst social connection offers people heaps of positive opportunities, the more connections, the more opportunities there is. for social comparison, and that's what social media does to us. It creates that upward social comparison that makes you feel shit about yourself. Think about this in the context of our 20s.
to compare yourself to other people. Limitless, there's thousands. And research predating social media, it estimated that the average person, you know, back in the 90s, back in the 1900s, had perhaps 10 to 20 close relationships and maybe 150 people in their wider social circle. So that includes, you know, like friends of your parents, colleagues, people you kind of know. Whereas now, that number of wider social acquaintances, because of social media, it's up to around 400. So whilst social connection offers people heaps of positive opportunities, the more connections, the more opportunities there is. for social comparison, and that's what social media does to us. It creates that upward social comparison that makes you feel shit about yourself. Think about this in the context of our 20s.|||来与其他人进行比较。无限的，有成千上万个。在社交媒体出现之前的研究估计，普通人，你知道的，在 90 年代，20 世纪 1900 年代，可能拥有 10 到 20 个亲密关系，在他们更广泛的社交圈里也许有 150 人。所以这包括，你知道的，比如你父母的朋友、同事、你认识的人。然而现在，由于社交媒体的存在，更广泛的社交熟人数量已经上升到 400 人左右。因此，虽然社交联系为人们提供了大量的积极机会，但连接越多，就会有越多的机会进行社会比较，这就是社交媒体对我们所做的事情。它创造了那种向上的社会比较，让你对自己的感觉像坨屎。在我们的二十几岁这一背景下来考虑这一点。
This is such a formative period for our self-esteem, for how we view ourselves, how we view others and our identity, and we spend hours of our daily life in an online environment of comparison. And the consequences of that aren't, you know, just felt today and tomorrow, but they're lifelong. And here's another related issue. This is the issue of self-presentation and identity. So social media, we've said, it affords you, the user, the ability to carefully curate and control how you present yourself to your audience. And people, you know, you and I, we generally choose to show an ideal image on social media.
This is such a formative period for our self-esteem, for how we view ourselves, how we view others and our identity, and we spend hours of our daily life in an online environment of comparison. And the consequences of that aren't, you know, just felt today and tomorrow, but they're lifelong. And here's another related issue. This is the issue of self-presentation and identity. So social media, we've said, it affords you, the user, the ability to carefully curate and control how you present yourself to your audience. And people, you know, you and I, we generally choose to show an ideal image on social media.|||这是我们自尊心、我们如何看待自己、如何看待他人以及我们的身份认同的至关重要的形成期，而我们在日常生活中花了好几个小时在一个充满比较的网络环境中。其后果不仅，你知道的，在今天和明天能感受到，而是终生的。这里还有另一个相关的问题。这就是自我呈现和身份认同的问题。因此，我们说过，社交媒体为你——用户——提供了精心策划和控制你向受众展示自己的方式的能力。而人们，你知道的，你和我，通常选择在社交媒体上展示一个理想的形象。
And in social psychology, two major motives are believed to influence this positive self-presentation. They are self-enhancement and self-verification. Self-enhancement, this motivates people to present an enhanced positive self-image and to seek favourable self-relevant information. Self-verification, on the other hand, drives people to verify or to maintain stability of their pre-existing self-views. So that first one is about, you know, presenting this enhanced view and seeing whether people like it. And the other is maintaining how you feel about yourself now and making sure that you continue to be validated for that. self-presentation theory suggests that people they have discretion as to how they present themselves
And in social psychology, two major motives are believed to influence this positive self-presentation. They are self-enhancement and self-verification. Self-enhancement, this motivates people to present an enhanced positive self-image and to seek favourable self-relevant information. Self-verification, on the other hand, drives people to verify or to maintain stability of their pre-existing self-views. So that first one is about, you know, presenting this enhanced view and seeing whether people like it. And the other is maintaining how you feel about yourself now and making sure that you continue to be validated for that. self-presentation theory suggests that people they have discretion as to how they present themselves|||在社会心理学中，人们认为有两个主要动机影响这种积极的自我呈现。它们是自我提升和自我验证。自我提升，这促使人们展示一个增强的积极自我形象，并寻求有利的与自我相关的信息。另一方面，自我验证促使人们验证或维持他们先前存在的自我看法的稳定性。所以第一个是关于，你知道的，呈现这种增强的观点，看看人们是否喜欢它。另一个是维持你现在对自己的看法，并确保你继续为此得到认可。自我呈现理论表明，人们对于如何呈现自己拥有自主权
in a variety of performances daily performances and social media is one such performance so the hyper personal model of behavior argues that with that self-presentation that ability to present who you want to be even if it's not real that is really promoted by computer mediated or social media mediated communication and that has advantages over face-to-face communication in how we optimize our self-presentation. Think about this a bit deeper. It's pretty obvious but really think about it. If you see someone in your daily life, you know, they're going to see your flaws. Maybe you like have a pimple. You know, they're going to see the mistakes that you mean. They're going to see that you're not perfect. But you have the opportunity to screen those parts of
每日有各种各样的表现形式，社交媒体就是其中之一。因此，超个人行为模型认为，自我呈现、展示你想成为之人的能力——即使那不是真实的——确实是通过计算机或社交媒体介导的交流来推广的。在如何优化自我呈现方面，这比面对面交流更有优势。深入思考一下。这其实很明显，但真的去想想看。如果你在日常生活中见到某人，你知道的，他们会看到你的缺点。也许你长了个青春痘。你知道的，他们会看到你犯的错误。他们会看到你并不完美。但你有机会在社交媒体上将这些部分过滤掉。
you out on social media. You have the opportunity to show yourself being incredibly happy when that might not actually be the case. This isn't really our true selves. And we can use social media as a shield for acknowledging not only who we truly are and our true values, but it's also distraction from what's truly going on because we can use that validation and self-enhancement to make us feel better to make us seem better to the people that we want to receive validation from, to the people that we want to impress, essentially. You know, you're probably asking yourself, surely this isn't very good for our mental health. What are the chances you would be correct? What gave it away? Time and time again, social media has been shown to promote negative experiences like that feeling
在社交媒体上，你有机会展现自己无比快乐的一面，而事实可能并非如此。这并不是真正的我们。我们可以用社交媒体作为盾牌，不仅不去面对真正的自我和真实的价值，它也是对现实的一种逃避。因为我们可以利用这种认同感和自我提升来让自己感觉更好，向那些我们希望得到认可的人、我们本质上想要留下好印象的人展现更好的自己。你知道的，你可能会问自己，这肯定对我们的心理健康不太好吧。猜猜看，你百分之百猜对了。是什么暴露了这一点？一次又一次，社交媒体被证明会助长负面体验，比如那种由于向上的社交比较而产生的对生活和外表的不足感。
of inadequacy about your life and appearances because of upward social comparison. And a study by this English author, Primark, found not Primark the store, Primark the person. It found a link between the use of multiple social media platforms and increased depression and anxiety symptoms in young people aged 19 to 32. That's probably you. That's my normal audience range, 19 to 32. And think about that again. If you use social media platforms, it could potentially be making you more anxious.
而且，英国作家普莱马克（Primark）的一项研究发现——不是普莱马克商店，是叫普莱马克的这个人——发现19至32岁的年轻人使用多个社交媒体平台与抑郁和焦虑症状增加之间存在关联。那可能就是你。那是我的正常受众年龄段，19到32岁。再想想这个。如果你使用社交媒体平台，它可能会让你变得更加焦虑。
It could be making you more depressed. From another angle, though, online platforms may also have the potential to damage mental well-being through this promotion of unreasonable expectations about what you look like and how you present. Social media, it's been linked to poor self-esteem and self-image because of the advent of image manipulation on Photoshop. platforms. You know, you can download FaceTune and make yourself look amazing. You can make yourself look skinnier. You can smooth out your skin. You can make your skin look glowy. And it's this idea of the idealized body image that has been promoted by social media
从另一个角度来看，在线平台也可能通过助长关于你的外表和表现的不合理期望来损害心理健康。由于Photoshop等图像处理平台的出现，社交媒体与糟糕的自尊心和自我形象联系在一起。你知道的，你可以下载FaceTune把自己P得惊艳动人。你可以让自己看起来更瘦。你可以磨平皮肤。你可以让皮肤看起来容光焕发。正是这种由社交媒体推广的理想化身材形象的概念，
that arguably has the most detrimental effect to self-esteem and image, especially that of young people. The 24-7 circulation of easily viewable, manipulated images promotes and entrenched those unrealistic expectations of how you should look and how you should behave. Think about all those photos,
可以说是对自尊和自我形象造成了最大的负面影响，尤其是对年轻人而言。全天候传播的、易于查看的被操纵图像，促进并巩固了关于你应该长成什么样、应该如何行为的不切实际的期望。想想所有那些照片，
you know, of Kim Kardashian that people like, you know, screenshot or like repost and then you find out that they're edited. Of course they are. No one looks like that. Like, have you ever seen anyone who looks like that? No. No. Like, you don't. And when these expectations we have
你知道的，金·卡戴珊的照片，人们喜欢，你知道的，截图或者转发，然后你发现它们是被修过的。当然是被修过的。没有人长那样。就像，你见过长那样的人吗？没有。没有。根本没有。当这些期望
for what we should look like, based on what we see on social media. When they're not met, the impact on self-esteem is so damaging. And it's really disturbing. You know, there was this study run by, like, the Australian government, like the health department, and it found that 90%, so 9 out of 10 young women that they interviewed, and they interviewed quite a few, say they were unhappy with how they look, and a big part of that was because of social media.
根据我们在社交媒体上看到的，对我们应该长成什么样进行设定，而这些期望又无法满足时，对自尊心的打击是极其巨大的。这真的很令人不安。你知道的，澳大利亚政府（比如卫生部门）做过这样一项研究，结果发现他们采访的年轻女性中，有90%（也就是10个里面有9个）——她们采访了相当多的人——表示对自己长相不满意，而其中很大一部分原因正是社交媒体。
Obviously, the rise of social media, it's incredibly multidis, faceted. It's, you know, we can't explain it simply. But the statistics they do suggest that it's strongly correlated, or at least associated with anxiety, loneliness, depression, social comparison. And I've been feeling that, you know, myself, I'm sure you have as well. Whether it is, you know, just a causal kind of thing based on the fact that there is other stuff shown on our feeds that could be depressing us like war and terror and awful things, it's going to have to, you know, time will kind of tell. And there is so much policy research into this and so much kind of talk around regulation with the social media industry today as well. A lot of what we've talked about,
显然，社交媒体的崛起极其多元且复杂。它，你知道的，我们无法简单地解释。但统计数据确实表明，它与焦虑、孤独、抑郁以及社交比较有着强烈的相关性，或者至少有联系。我自己也一直在这种感觉，我相信你也是。不管它是，你知道的，仅仅基于我们的动态中展示了其他可能让我们感到沮丧的内容（如战争、恐怖和可怕的事情）这一事实所产生的因果关系，时间会说明一切。如今，关于这方面的政策研究非常多，围绕社交媒体行业的监管讨论也非常多。我们讨论的很多内容，
it's probably not new to you and there are definitely some elements of social media that are really, I would say, beneficial and pretty incredible when you think back. For example, for example, You know, the war in Ukraine at the moment. We would know so much less than we do if people didn't have the ability to share their experiences on the ground with people across the world. This is the same with other wars and revolutions
对你来说可能并不新鲜，而且社交媒体确实有一些元素真的非常、可以说是有益的，回想起来相当惊人。例如，例如，你知道的，目前的乌克兰战争。如果没有人有能力与世界各地的人分享他们在实地的亲身经历，我们所了解到的信息就会少得多。自社交媒体诞生以来，其他战争和革命也是如此。
since social media kind of became a thing. The Me Too movement, election mobilization. Social media, it's also a source of connection and information sharing that may not be accessible elsewhere or in another manner. Another thing that kind of comes to mind is how social media can be used to help educate people about movements like Black Lives Matter and spread awareness around things. You know, I think about when that girl went missing in W.A. That was all over social media. That's, you know, definitely something to be positive about, that instantaneous communication platform.
“我也是”（Me Too）运动、选举动员。社交媒体也是一个连接和信息共享的来源，这些可能是通过其他地方或方式无法获得的。我想到的另一件事是，社交媒体如何被用来帮助教育人们了解诸如“黑人的命也是命”（Black Lives Matter）之类的运动，并在周围传播意识。你知道的，我想起那个女孩在西澳失踪的时候。那在社交媒体上到处都是。这，你知道的，绝对是值得肯定的积极一面，即这种即时传播平台。
And that's what it was meant to be at its purest form, but it's really not that anymore. And although there are some good things, all of these good things, things are happening in a virtual environment that is deliberately creating addiction and it's hijacking our synaptic connections and our dopamine centers to essentially make money for big organizations through ad revenue and it's kind of running our minds and changing the very structure of our brains like I said and that's obviously not going to change any time soon like every year there's just more and more ways that our society kind of caters towards social media like TikTok now is a marketing platform. I was actually thinking this the other day.
这本该是它最纯粹形式下的样子，但现在真的已经不是了。尽管有一些好的方面，但所有这些好的方面都发生在一个虚拟环境中，这个虚拟环境蓄意制造着成瘾，它劫持了我们的突触连接和多巴胺中心，本质上是通过广告收入为大机构赚钱。它在某种程度上操纵着我们的思想，改变着我们的大脑结构，就像我说的，这显然不会很快改变。就像每年都有越来越多迎合社交媒体的社会方式一样，比如TikTok现在成了营销平台。我前几天其实还在想这个。
Like I don't see billboards for movies anymore. I don't see like ads in the paper. Like I don't see like magazine articles about it. I see it on TikTok or I see it on Instagram. And that's how I know like, you know, the Batman came out or something like that. Those are the kind of things that I'm talking about of how it's changed, how we relate to the world and communicate and how we get our knowledge. Anyways, I hope that you enjoyed this episode.
就像我再也看不到电影的巨幅广告牌了。我看不到报纸上的广告。我看不到关于它的杂志文章。我是在TikTok或Instagram上看到的。这就是我如何得知《蝙蝠侠》上映之类的事情。这就是我所说的例子，它改变了我们与世界的关系、交流方式以及我们获取知识的方式。无论如何，希望你喜欢这集节目。
I had a lot of fun researching this. I learned so much. And I think especially with the social comparison ideas we've been talking about, it's really at least inspired me to take some time off social media, to turn off notifications, to kind of limit how much I use it, how dependent I am on it, how much I post, how much I share, and just kind of spend more time in the present moment doing the things I love. like when I was in Queensland recently,
我在做这个研究时玩得很开心。我学到了很多。而且我认为，特别是在我们一直在讨论的社交比较观念方面，它至少启发了我，让我花一些时间远离社交媒体，关闭通知，限制我使用它的频率、对它的依赖程度、我发帖的频率、分享的频率，并花更多时间活在当下，去做我热爱的事情。就像我最近在昆士兰的时候，
I would just try and make like a conscious effort to like leave my phone in the car when I was going to the beach because I noticed if I brought my phone, I would literally be sitting there in front of some of the most beautiful water and clear skies, a girl confined during Linena
我只是试图有意识地努力，当我准备去海滩时把手机留在车里，因为我注意到如果我带了手机，我就会真的坐在那里，面对着一些最美丽的水景和清澈的天空——在拉尼娜现象期间好不容易才放晴的蓝天——
and I would be on my phone and I wouldn't even remember what was going on around me and I wouldn't remember what was going on on my phone either and you're just kind of blind to your life in that moment, aren't you? Anyhow, thank you for listening. Thank you for subscribing if you have. If not, your choice, but please do. It would be very lovely.
而我却在刷手机，甚至不记得周围发生了什么，而且我也不记得手机上发生了什么，你在那一刻对自己的生活视而不见，对吧？无论如何，谢谢你收听。感谢订阅（如果你已经订阅了的话）。如果没有，随你选择，但请订阅吧。那会非常可爱。
And if you feel cool to leave a review on either Spotify or Apple Podcasts, it's so lovely. I've been getting so many reviews and it makes me so, so happy, makes me a very happy girl. So if you feel cool to do it, please do. It takes a couple seconds. It makes my day. You'll feel good about yourself unless you want to stop using your phone as much because of social media addiction, in which case don't do it
如果你愿意在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上留个好评，那就太好了。我收到了那么多好评，这让我感到非常非常开心，让我成了一个非常快乐的女孩。所以如果你愿意做的话，请去做吧。只需要几秒钟。这能让我一整天都有好心情。除非你想因为社交媒体成瘾而少用手机，在这种情况下就别去了
stay away but we'll be back next week I'm going to talk about love languages because that sounds exciting right and a friend of my
远离它。但我们下周会回来，我要聊聊爱的语言，因为听起来很令人兴奋，对吧？我和一个朋友
one of my friends and I were discussing it the other day and I was like this is really interesting I want to see whether there is actually like research behind this
我的一个朋友前几天在讨论这个，然后我说这真的很有趣，我想看看这背后是不是真的有什么研究，
whether this is like legit so that's what we're going to be talking about next week until then we've got so many episodes on Spotify at the moment if you want to listen back
看看这是否合法合规，所以这就是我们下周要讨论的内容。在此之前，如果你想回顾的话，我们在Spotify上有很多节目
and just have a great week. Enjoy your life. Enjoy yourself in the moment. And turn off Instagram. It will be good for you. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs
祝大家度过美好的一周。享受生活。享受当下的自己。关掉Instagram。这对你有好处。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在这样一个陌生现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J.
你就会破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2%”，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个大日子。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个时代，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难一课》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的执业专业人士进行交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有多少男人穿着铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难一课》。这是一档IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。